Brenda wine Apple author of a life
Hawthorne
how much did politics play in his life
it played a much larger role than people
have liked to think he was a political
man he was involved in politics and he
was best friends with arguably one of
the worst American presidents which is
saying something
Franklin Pierce Franklin Pierce how did
he get to know Franklin Pierce
they met at college they weren't voting
together Pierce was a year ahead of
Hawthorne Pierce was a very gregarious
outgoing warm and genial person and he
and Hawthorne became friends
they actually marched together in a
little group called the Bowdoin Cadets
one doesn't think of Hawthorne marching
and certainly not marching behind anyone
but they did and also politics at
Bowdoin was very important they were
both what became Democrats they were
Jeffersonian Republicans at the time so
that was a very important connection
between the two men then they stayed
friends for their entire lives Bowdoin
had I think 38 people in the graduating
class that included Pierce and Nathaniel
Hawthorne but there were three for I
mean a three congressmen came out of
that same class yeah
Pierce was after the class ahead of
Hoffman it was a Hawthorne class which
was the class of 25 was very well-known
because I think John Russ worm who was
the first president of Liberia the
colony the American colony where
emancipated slaves were sent for a while
he was a member of the bogan class henry
wadsworth longfellow from a whole other
perspective was a member of the Bowdoin
class another very good friend of
Hawthorne Horatio bridge was a member of
that class so was a it was a famous
class still I think in Bowdoin annals
when did you first get interested in a
thing of Hawthorne oh it's hard to say
probably as a school child I remember
reading the minister's black veil which
schoolchildren had to do and being
completely horrified and I never forgot
it I was horrified because I didn't
understand it and later I realised it
was all right not to understand it so I
think Hawthorn grabs people at a certain
point in one's life and it never lets go
and long after I decided to write a
biography of Hawthorne I realized that
my previous book which was on a very
different subject Gertrude Stein and her
brother Leo actually began with an
epigraph from Hawthorne from Hawthorne
Scarlet Letter so obviously I'd been
thinking about him for a long time when
did he live he was born in 1804 the
bicentennial of his birth is coming up
next year July 4th 1804 and he died in
1864 just before the end of the Civil
War you quote somebody by the name of
Elizabeth Peabody saying he wanted to
die by the time he was 59 yeah he did he
was anxious about turning 60 most people
he'd already said you know he didn't
think he'd lived past 21 and that kind
of romantic flourish when he told
Peabody that Peabody was his
sister-in-law he was ill he was ill by
that time and one way of interpreting it
is to say he didn't want to live as an
ailing and failing person the places
that he lived just give us a quick
overview he was born in Salem
Massachusetts he's descended from very
famous Salem Hawthorne's hey thorns
actually as the name was spelled but he
also lived in Concord Massachusetts for
a time he lived in Lenox for a time he
lived in Liverpool England for time he
lived in Rome for a time for a brief
time he lived in Florence one summer and
then at the end of his life he'd come
back to Concord where he had bought a
house and he lived and was buried in
Concord you say that when he died he was
worth $26,000 yeah
how much would that be today any idea I
don't know it's a good question um the
reason I brought it up was what I said
at the end was that it was enough to
keep him out of the almshouse by the end
of his life because he'd been ill and
when you're ill you can't write and he
didn't have political jobs he was
worried about the maintenance of his
family he had a wife and three children
so $26,000 was more than it was enough
to make him comfortable
I mean included his real estate and so
forth it wasn't a huge amount by any
means at all
but it was more than he thought he had
he'd saved a lot of that money while he
was the consulship why he was consul for
Liverpool under the Pierce
administration and part of the reason he
took that job was to make oh it was a
very lucrative job to make that money
you said at the time a good house would
cost three thousand dollars yeah but you
also said at the time in order to get
stay out of the Civil War
you could spend $300 right that's right
that's right yeah what did he do in
connection with war well he was too old
to fight didn't had he it's it's unclear
whether he would have wanted to or not
some days he felt he wanted to grab that
musket and and shoot someone but mostly
he was so horrified by the bloodletting
that was the Civil War because daily
there were reports of friends of his
children or nephews being lost or or
maimed or or runaway something like that
and he was he was aghast at the whole
thing he was he was he was brutalized by
the war and he was very critical of the
north and of the south
both say he's anti-war I would say he
was anti-war yeah which is an anomalous
thing to be in that time it's almost as
if you know the modern corollary would
be anti-war although some people were
Robert law during the Second World War
and now to us we think well how could
you have been on anti-nazi how could you
have been anti-war well there was a way
in in a civil war for a northerner
in Concord Massachusetts neighbor of of
Thoreau neighbor of Emerson to be
anti-war when in point of fact the war
was being fought from these people's
point of view
to emancipate the slaves you know to get
rid of slavery isn't is a strange
position some of the books some of the
better-known books that he wrote oh
you're asking the scarlet letter the
most famous absolutely the most famous
of the House of the Seven Gables The
Scarlet Letter is still sort of a a
mainstay canonical mainstay in school
curricula all throughout the country the
house of Seven Gables the Blithedale
romance not read as often but a strange
little book and the marble faun those
are the four main Hawthorne books and
he's also known for shorties stories
like the one I mentioned the minister's
black veil the birthmark rapid genies
daughter
whichever one happens to be somebody's
favorite that they read as I did you
know when they were about 12 years old
but you also say at one point he would
sell 7,000 copies of The Scarlet Letter
where Harriet Beecher Stowe was selling
three hundred thousand three hundred
thousand Tom's Cabin yeah seven yeah
right put that in context and did he
ever sell a lot scarlet letter no no he
never sold a lot I think he made overall
no I think overall between the time of
the publication in 1850 the Scarlet
Letter in the time of his death 1864 he
sold 13,500 copies that was in a 14-year
period 300,000 copies of Harriet Beecher
Stowe in one year so that gives you a
sense of the difference the scarlet
letter was a success the steam people
knew of it it was an important book but
people weren't running out to buy it in
the same way they were right running out
to buy you know stoves book on one hand
or the narratives of life of Frederick
Douglass which became an international
bestseller in the 1840s Hawthorne was a
much more specialized or writer for a
more specialized audience people knew of
the
it had a certain kind of fame but it
didn't have what you'd call popular
almost journalistic success and that of
course was hard for him he has a
terrible and famous phrase about the
damned mob of scribbling women and what
he means by that although it's
complicated is he means these were women
primarily who were writing topical books
about current events who were selling
much more than he was and certainly much
more than say Melville who didn't you
know who's Moby Dick was an abysmal
failure something like that so he did
every relationship with Melville he did
have a relationship remember you say at
one point that Herman Melville loved him
yeah what did you mean mother mean
everything by it I mean we can't know
literally what is meant by it
um Melville Hawthorne was older than
Melville Melville lost his father
Melville had a kind of polymorphous
sexuality was very open to attachments
to men women sings whales
what-have-you and when he read Hawthorne
Moss is from an Old Manse a group of
short stories and just at the same time
as they met Hawthorne's unclear which
happened first he was he was overwhelmed
he was overpowered by the man who is so
enormous ly handsome and so smart so
reserved so satiric and so
philosophically compatible both in his
person and in his writing so Melville
was enamored of him and Melville always
wore his heart on his sleeve and wrote
gushing erotic letters to Hawthorne the
sad thing is that Hawthorne's letters
don't survive so we don't really know
his side of the correspondence but he
was a very different kind of man than
Melville was and so if you divide the
world into Melville lovers and Hawthorne
lovers as spurious a way to divide the
world is anything then people who love
Melville often dislike Hawthorne because
they feel that Hawthorne rejected
Melville
and so forth and so on it's not true
they were good friends
I don't think Hawthorne was in love with
Melville though how many different jobs
did Nathaniel Hawthorne have that he
required a political appointment quite a
number starting at the Boston custom
house before he was married in the 1830s
and that required political maneuvering
of George Bancroft through Elizabeth
Peabody the woman who had became a
sister-in-law so that was an early one
just a second George Bancroft turns out
to be a big name in history big name in
history why well because he started well
first of all because he wrote the
history one of the first and very
important histories of the United States
you know multi-volume history of the
United States where he gave he and in
some sense started the whole view of
America I mean it was always part of
sort of the American scene but America
is getting better and better as
progressive history she was a kind of
progressive historian and he also saw
America as kind of the great white hope
of democracy you know sort of changing
the world he was also a very important
Democratic Party leader and he had
several important posts in various
administrations and in Massachusetts
where he lived he pulled a lot of levers
for Democratic operatives so he was very
important and in lots of ways his finger
almost in every pot do you remember who
he was secretary of the Navy for know
which president sorry I was thinking was
I didn't want to bring it up because I
couldn't remember but then they today
they have a big history award Bancroft
maybe my Van Buren he might have been
from home but they had the bank robber
yeah yeah that's right
okay he he was a he got the job at the
Boston Christmas let me stop and ask you
though about custom houses because those
that name is used that's also one of his
books but what is the custom house in
those days well it was a clearinghouse
for imported and exported but primarily
imported goods coming into the country
and all of the
commerce international commerce was done
by ship and so we're Hawthorne was from
Salem for example just just a the in the
18th century and about until the time of
Hawthorne's birth and early years 1804
to about eighteen say eleven Salem was a
major port of entry for Goods coming
from as far away as China for example
the Far East say um see the East India
Company all came in through Salem it
actually surpassed Boston as a kind of
port of entry so it was very very
important
maritime commercial center later boston
surpassed it later in new york under the
sort of what happened is some this gets
into too much history but before the war
of 1812 jefferson had an embargo which
pretty much killed off salem commerce in
any case um so to work in the custom
houses to really be at the clearinghouse
i was looking at the manifests looking
at the goods that are coming in seeing
who owes what to whom so forth and so on
so it's important but very political job
these were political appointments so
again he was born in 1804 and this was
about 1830 did you say what do you in
the late 1830s right okay so what was
next what next political appointment it
again the next major one major was the
salem custom house and this was he got
this during the Polk administration
after Hawthorne was married he and his
bride Sophia Peabody Hawthorne moved to
Concord Massachusetts where they rented
a house they she was painting he was
writing they weren't making a lot of
money they were they were really poor
and so friends of Hawthorne's like
Pierce everybody else he knew he knew a
number of very political people john
o'sullivan
the man who coined the term manifest
destiny all worked hard to get Hawthorne
almost literally out of the kitchen
because they couldn't afford hired help
and his wife was pregnant I into a
political appointment and they went to
Bancroft and whoever else they had to
once the Democrats were back in power
eventually Hawthorne got the Salem
custom house what she wanted very much
the family moved back to Salem and he
was there until a rotation in office
Democrats are voted out the Whigs were
voted in Hawthorn was kicked out and
there was quite a brouhaha so that was
the next major appointment and that
lasted until 18-49 it's a matter of fact
you wrote page 380 he stood for dark
doubt and the Democratic Party Start was
the Democratic Party what was the
Democratic Party back in the 1800s 1850s
it developed out of Jackson well it's
the sort of Jacksonian democrats and the
and the Democratic Party in those years
was more like today's Republicans
important to sort of remember who became
what the Democrats stood very strongly
for states rights and as a result early
on they became a party associated with
expansion manifest destiny as I said
expanding territories to the west even
to the south and partly as a consequence
of that they also became associated with
pro-slavery a large part of the
Democratic Party was Pro slavery was a
pro-slavery wing it separated out later
on as his politics got even more dicey
than they were but it was also a
Progressive Party in that it was for
working person it was stood against the
kind of moneyed capitalist aristocracy
say of Boston which was associated with
the Whigs so by Hawthorne and then
Pierce and his friends at Bowdoin
joining with the Jacksonian Democrats
they felt that they were joining with
something that was youthful exciting
exuberant offered a kind of real hope
and egalitarianism for America which was
true as long as you were my white male
but that was true and that was
the vision so it was a kind of the it
was a kind of party in a sense of
optimism a kind of party of reform -
which is interesting because then later
when it becomes associated with Pro
slave pro-slavery forces we tend to then
think of that party as being a
conservative benighted reactionary it
was more complicated than that the
Republicans rose out of the Whig party
that was against the Democrats in the
anti-slavery Whigs
for the conscience wigs and the
anti-slavery Democrats joined forces
eventually by 1860 elected Lincoln as a
Republican Hawthorn stayed true to the
Democratic Party all the way through
even though lots of people left it
became either if they didn't become
Whigs that would be too hard be Kant
went to the Republicans because after
all the Republicans seemed to promise
some of the things that the Democrats
stood for but also anti-slavery
Hawthorne did not so he was in the most
he stayed with the most conservative
part of the Democratic Party which
eventually fell apart by the way in the
middle of you're clear where you're
talking about Nathaniel Hawthorne and
being poverty-stricken having no money
all of a sudden now the page pops he had
a cook how can your to cook if you were
part of different than different well
the eventually they had to get rid of
the [ __ ] but you have to realized that
help cost and these were the cook
general Walter was one in Lenox is a
black woman who came in and in Concord
to his an Irish woman who came in and
worked really for pennies so that even
the poor middle class whites or the sort
of lower middle class whites were better
off than the immigrants so he worked at
the Boston Custom House the Salem Custom
House lost his job and the politics
change what other government job to do
well then he had a big one then he had
an exciting one when Pierce when
Franklin Pierce was running for office
in the election of 1852 his friend
Nathaniel Hawthorne wrote
the campaign biography which is which
was basically out there in order to sell
Pierce's candidacy now Hawthorne is
we've established wasn't a best-selling
author but he was pretty much a
household name he was already fairly
canonical which is interesting this
Hawthorn stock has never gone now so
here he is writing the campaign
biography of Franklin Pierce he who
writes so-called high arc
to reward him which is probably part of
the plan and there's nothing wrong with
it
Pierce gave him Hawthorne the lucrative
post in Liverpool which is the console
sort of an ambassadorial post in
Liverpool England another major port and
and it was it it was intended by
Hawthorne and piers for Hawthorne to go
there spend the four years and to use
Hawthorne Stern bag as much money as he
could so eventually he could come back
to the United States and not have to
worry about an income he was a man who
really had to worry about how to live
you know Emerson didn't have to worry
about it in the same way for example
because he had a legacy his first wife
left him enough money Hawthorne was
always worried about getting food on the
table for his three children and his
wife so he this was a political
appointment that was manufactured really
for him and it already existed but given
to Hawthorne because Hawthorne really
needed it very much there was
psychological reasons for it's useful
for him too but those were the economic
ones but the interesting thing that you
point out about Liverpool and being
council there is that one year at least
one year he made ten grand yeah that's
in 1853 or for ten grand right houses
cost three grand right he did well as I
said he came back he how did he do this
so because that wasn't a government
salary oh no there was there was
corruption in a sense but but not
corruption that he was corrupt but built
into the system in fact one of the
reasons he started to he began to think
about quitting was that
there were consular laws going or bills
being passed and talked about in
Congress to to put an end to the I guess
we'd almost call them kickbacks every
time Hawthorne signed if an official
sheet of something coming in manifest or
okayed shipments he would get money
basically under the table so that he and
it was legal this was a legal procedure
so people in these posts knew that not
only did they get the allowance for
their family and and their housing and
whatever but also that they were allowed
to take it wasn't even under the table
they were allowed to take for their
signature on every official document
couple of dollars that added up quite
quickly
he knew it everybody knew it that was
part of the deal that's why the reforms
that started in the 1850s and as soon as
Hawthorne got wind of that Pierce tried
to delay them a little bit because he
knew what was happening also and thought
I better get you know there's no point
to staying that's how he made it yeah
you said Nathaniel Hawthorne spent seven
years overseas from 52 on right but for
those years with council and Liverpool
right but that point you may about
Franklin Pierce when he was president
stopped that the counselor you know the
what's the word changing the law yeah
that by saying it was unconstitutional
yeah and was he able to stop her for the
whole four years
no he but he slowed it down enormous Lee
enough to get Hawthorne out and him up
go back to though the biography and
almost all the lists you see of books it
Nathaniel Hawthorne wrote they don't
list I don't mean you but they don't
often you don't see the list of the
biography of Franklin Pierce how big of
that's interesting I mean that never
dawned on me you mean how long a book
was it it was about 250 pages it was
long enough I mean I was read it
have I read oh yeah oh it's fascinating
why well first of all its Hawthorne it
has the signature of hawthorn the
sentences are elegant and beautifully
balanced and he gives them one hand and
takes away on the other he won't perjure
himself he won't say you know Pierce is
a great person he says purse is great
for the job something like that but from
another point of view you know quite not
just literary although literary is
connected to it it also demonstrates
Hawthorne's view of the constitution of
slavery and of politics he's not mincing
words he doesn't have the veil in front
of his face he's very clear about what
he thinks and what he thinks about what
Pierce things and because Pierce backs
the Constitution
Hawthorne sinks he's the man for the job
because Hawthorne himself believes in
the Constitution which makes sense when
you think about it he was he was a
cynical man who was conscious that were
capable of doing terrible things to one
another and for him law the Constitution
is a kind of document that prevents
demagoguery the demagoguery of say the
witch trials or whatever in this you
know in the 17th century or the
demagoguery that he would be a little
bit skeptical about visiting Lincoln you
know it prevents mob rule all of those
things but really believed in the
Constitution here you have a man that
was born in the Northeast and also
Franklin Pierce from Concord New
Hampshire yeah and he was a Democrat
elected in 1852 for years only what was
he about why was he so pro-slavery I you
know it's a terrible one more dancer I
wouldn't say this about Hawthorne but
was the first word that comes to my mind
when you asked me that question is he's
stupid but that's not a good answer
why was he pro-slavery in that in that
way I think because he lacked the
imagination to think of what it really
is to be a slave you know I mean I think
was it's a real failure some it's a
failure of moral nerve and if
it's failure of imagination that comes
to Paris but he didn't bother to think
about it he's never got beyond the rule
of law so it wasn't real to him maybe
being from the Northeast had something
to do with it maybe being as most people
were whether it was Hawthorne at one
extreme or he's been Theodore Parker at
the other extreme maybe being racist had
something to do with it but he believed
that and and maybe there was some valve
elyda t21 argument that if the
institution of slavery the institution
is reprehensible
which it is they agreed about that they
disagreed about the means by which it
should be changed and in a sense Paris
was a quietest Pierce thought you just
leave it alone and eventually it'll go
away
Hawthorne thought that to actually how
do you ever get elected president Pierce
yeah darkhorse you know I mean the sort
of mechanics of of the election of 1852
were such that he was able to get in I
don't remember on which ballot but
eventually he was able to get in and is
also because he didn't he offended the
least amount of people it was one of
those kinds of candidates that you know
the South could deal with him the South
thought it was okay and the north while
he was at still still a northerner
instove as you said from Concord so that
he had so represented the north and the
south and he he tried not to say too
much she wouldn't talk about the
Fugitive Slave Law
for example even though he was foreign
and because people liked him he was
evidently to meet him a very personable
charming guy you say they were together
when nathaniel hawthorne died yeah they
were as I mentioned Hoffman was ill he'd
been progressively ill it's hard to say
exactly what he had and he wanted he'd
already taken one failed journey for his
house very tragically because his editor
one of his editors happen to die on that
trip
so Hawthorn health clearly didn't
improve especially to the extent that it
was psychologically driven
and his wife Sofia thought that it would
be good for him to take another trip the
only person he would go with his
Franklin Pierce he loved Pierce you want
to talk about people loving each other
these two men loved each other and
Pierce came to Boston and Sofia took
Nathaniel into Boston and they went in
Pierce's carriage up through New
Hampshire too and eventually they went
to Plymouth and that's where Hawthorne
died in the pema gossiped in employment
where is he buried today Concord covered
massacred Massachusetts
yeah not New Hampshire and Franklin
Pierce is Concord New Hampshire right
your approach to this book I know you
got some letters in the middle of all
this special letters have never been
seen before
yeah they yes I was visiting a group of
Hawthorne's in Connecticut early on
actually and one of them pressed phone
number into my hand and she said a niece
of hers had found an old tin trunk under
leaky pipe and by the time I got home
the niece had called I went out there
and she had a trunk filled with family
letters they actually the family letters
went way into the 20th century
there were no letters of Hawthorne but
there were there were there were a lot
of letters of his wife and of his
children or my sister-in-law and there
was some material of Longfellow Emerson
it was wonderful it was really who's
alive today that's connected with the
family in any way Julian's descendants
Julian son son of Nathaniel Hawthorne
had three children one son the son had
ten children eight of whom lips whose a
lot of children and these descendants
through Julian through these eight
great-grandchildren they're all over the
place what did you learn from the
letters of Sofia his wife well I learned
a great deal about life in the Hawthorne
household I learned a tremendous amount
about her because she was she as a wife
she was Hawthorne 'he's best and most
faithful publicist both within the
family and outside the family
she was wonderful to him she was she was
boolean and undaunted in her faith in
him I also learned a lot about how they
raised their children what they read
what they ate there was an enormous
amount that I learned through her
letters because she was she was
unreserved where he was reserved he was
unreserved and she wrote I don't know
how people had the time to write the
kinds of letters that they wrote and do
everything else they did in a day what's
the story of Sofia and her sister and
their relationship to a Nathaniel
Hawthorne so if I had three two sisters
rather there were three of them and the
one you're probably referring to as
Elizabeth we mentioned her before and
Elizabeth was the take-charge sister
never married who in a sense felt she
and in a way discovered Hawthorne for
the Peabody family and became also his
publicist booster helped him get the job
in the Boston custom house and very
likely fell in love with him by the way
is this the Peabody family the indicate
Peabody family there's a vice-president
no no no not politicians at all no no no
no I'm distantly related but this is the
poorer branch of the Peabody family no
no no this Peabody family has Sophia the
sister married a Hawthorne Mary Peabody
who married Horace Mann the educator and
also the congressman and then Elizabeth
who actually brought kindergarten to the
United States they were very interesting
Elizabeth Peabody brought kindergarten
to the United States yeah how yeah well
she read about it she went over to
Germany she was a schoolteacher she
worked with Bronson Alcott and she
developed early childhood education
techniques what's the relationship of
Bronson Alcott a few buddies no why
can't I think of her name Louisa sis
father
Ouisa May Alcott yeah sir father father
yeah Bronson was her father
so that was Bronson Alcott in Hawthorne
of the that generation and then and then
Louisa May Alcott is Bronson Alcott
daughter and say for example Henry James
senior the next Henry James would be
this that we know one generation down
you got a lot of big names here let's go
over all no no I mean I mean well no
names he a Horace Mann Horace Mann
Horace Mann brother-in-law - Nathaniel
Hawthorne anti-slavery activist but not
an abolitionist was horrified when
Hawthorne wrote the book we were talking
about the life of Franklin Paris and he
said how could he write such a book
basically is he's such a man that would
do this sighs his brother-in-law yeah
Ralph Waldo Emerson you mentioned
earlier Emerson neighbor the in Concord
man in Concord mass the first place that
Hawthorne lived in Concord mass with his
wife was rented from Emerson
step-grandfather I mean it's very almost
incestuous in a certain sense there's a
very small community but when anybody
goes to the Old North Bridge right and
Concord mass where the Revolutionary War
started in that area in Lexington they
see the old house sitting right there
exactly that's the old man so yeah they
rented that they rented that that's
where the newlyweds lived
did he ever own it no how long did they
live there they lived there from the
time their marriage 1842 to the time
they basically had to leave because they
couldn't afford the rent anymore and
that was three years later that's when
they went back to Salem so Ralph Lauren
and de and Henry David Thoreau is in the
same community absolutely absolutely and
Thoreau worked for Emerson was friends
with Emerson so sort of in some sense
some Tootsie of Emerson but then from
some points of view of surpassed Emerson
Hawthorne and Thoreau were good friends
too in some ways better friends than
Hawthorne and Emerson who were more like
rivals Hawthorne bought the Rose boat
called the pond lily that to help throw
up throat didn't have much money there
but he really liked throne respected
Thoreau they were both kind of sardonic
men unusual men eccentric men and in
some ways loners even though is
Nathaniel Hawthorne on authors Ridge
yeah right there with all the rest of
yeah
now Emerson is in the vanguard Lim
ursins down the road there half a block
in the same is a big boulder go back to
Henry longfellow who you mentioned
earlier Longfellow and did man also go
to Bowden no but Bowdoin College is
where and what was the significance of
them all ending up Franklin Pierce and
Henry longfellow and and others at
Bowdoin well if you mean why didn't they
each go there I think I mean where is it
first oh it's in Maine alright it's in
and I'm Brunswick Maine and it's still
there probably looks very very similar
to the way it looked then beautiful
campus very chilly in the winter oh and
now even with central heating I imagine
it was for me anyway it would have been
horrible it was so I think that the
students often warmed themselves with
quite a bit of liquor and any event
Longfellow went there I think for
different kinds of reasons that then
Pierce or Hawthorne did Longfellow came
from a well-established family in Maine
and his father was on the board of
trustees so Longfellow was in a
different literary and - political
society than Hawthorne and Pierce
Hawthorne was coming his family sent him
to Bowdoin because they liked the
orthodoxy the religious orthodoxy of
Bowdoin and although Hawthorne didn't
appreciate that as it turned out he
liked the politics that were available
to him which was the sort of Young
America Democrats so that's why they all
went there Hawthorne and Longfellow
didn't know each other well they knew
each other didn't know each other well
at Bowdoin it was afterwards that they
got in touch and Longfellow was probably
one of the nicest men in American
literature very generous very kind and
and really helpful to Hawthorne in his
early career
is there anything comparable today is
there an author today that would write
up
agra fee of a presidential candidate an
author today who would want an
appointment to work in the government
that's a good question I wish I could
think of something snappy offhand but
what I what I do say as a counter Weiner
to show how unusual it is I would say
the people in Hawthorne and Pierce's
relationship would be as if or to sort
of one is like JD Salinger of writing a
campaign biography of George Bush I mean
one doesn't imagine that in that way I
imagine that there probably are people
who might do it but no one springs to
mind because we generally I think
separate out politics in art politics
this year art is over there and they're
not supposed to come together you know
so we see a lot of actors getting
involved now is there any similar more
like popular art and that comes you know
in Clinton was sort of you know
straddled that in a certain way he
brought in sort of rock music and pop
art and Hollywood into the political
arena high art still sort of stays where
what passes for high art stays pretty
much by itself in that realm this book
here I guess with all the indexes and
everything in it you're talking about
500 pages
is there anybody today in in this
country who's writing for a living do
you think would warrant a biography like
this a hundred and fifty years you know
well yeah I mean it would be it would be
inappropriate probably to name names but
let me say this range I'm trying to
relate to in other words to get some
sense of how important yeah the Fanueil
Hoffman was then and how important some
writers would be today that they would
actually get a biography written about
him hundred fifty years later well I
mean it happens it's not the kind of
work I'm interested in but but someone
like I saw Bella for example
I'm you could say that there's a
political side to his character although
not directly so but you know not working
in government he's still alive and had a
very large larger than this biography
written about him so and so in 150 years
whatever you know part of the part of
the sort of heft of a book like this too
is it has to do with creating a kind of
record much for getting the index but
the notes are there for other people who
want to write their own book so check me
out or something like yeah now I always
consider two books there's the book
there's the notes for the people who
were interested in that and then there's
the text that that I don't want to
interrupt the story in a sense with the
material for the notes from from how
important was Nathaniel Hawthorne in the
1850s in the country how many people
would know who he was I think a number
of people people were literate there
were lots of newspapers lots of mega
even more becoming more and more
magazines I mean there was a penny press
developing - could you buy books in the
South sure all over the country sure
although you say Scarlet Letter 7,000
copies yeah well yeah it's like now you
know it doesn't see it wouldn't seem
like a lot if we didn't have the other
figures to say that some books really
sold quite a bit but people know who he
was I mean there's not a year goes by
that The Scarlet Letter doesn't sell
quite a few more than 7,000 today now
now sure and probably since he died more
and more became more and more valuable
you know especially as it became more
and more part of it as I said before a
school curriculum you know that accounts
for sales right there and then the
scarlet letter itself almost has its own
life you know there are plays movies
hoppers based on it
suzan-lori parks did I kind of take off
on it you know in in New York last year
so so it's it's become part of the
fabric
really when did you start the book I
started the book shortly after not too
long after I finished the last one so it
was around the end of 96
I started Feliz you know what was
available was it really a good book to
write what would Hawthorne people think
about it
you know things like that was the last
time there was a Hawthorne biography the
last major major one was over 20 years
ago
and there was one but there was one in
between it was more sort of Freudian
analysis in 1990 and from what position
did you do the research and write the
book what do you do on a full-time basis
on a full-time basis I like to think I
write but I also teach like Hawthorne
I'm not in the government I don't have
government jobs but I teach I teach for
a living where I teach I have taught for
many years at Union College and
Schenectady New York and what's special
about Union College from a historical
standpoint well it's the first
non-sectarian college in the United
States which is really rather remarkable
given the sectarian nature of of early
American education and and started in
the 18th century so it has a long
venerable tradition on C Henry James's
grandfather was a trustee there Chester
Arthur yo and Chester a Arthur it has
its own sort of political commitment how
long have you been there do I have to
answer that yes 20-some years and where
did you come from to there where'd you
go to school where did you I'm from New
England and in fact my father's from
Salem Massachusetts I'm from Haverhill
Massachusetts which is a mill town or a
factory town and the Merrimack you know
River Valley in Northeast Massachusetts
and from there I went not very far to
college and went to Brandeis University
which is in Waltham what'd you study I
studies American and English literature
primarily
and do you know I mean you examine this
life do you know in your own life why
you are interested in writing mmm
writers literature teaching I love to
read though where did I get it where I
get my love to read escape probably did
your parents do it
my parents do it I thought there's a
slow reader my mother is a faster more
prolific reader but um I think I read
obsessively and they don't and I think I
started reading obsessively excuse me at
a very young age as I said is a kind of
travel in a way that was a very it was a
wonderful form of escape and almost self
education and I spent I had a
complicated childhood so I spent a lot
of time reading and alone doing that
it's probably a lot of readers do the
readers want to become writers really in
some ways you want to answer back I
think and and so I think that's probably
where it began why do you say you had a
complicated childhood I write I you know
I don't enter into my own books I mean
I'm sure that they're all kinds of
psychological reasons even to choose
Hawthorne who's a new New England author
you know it's very appealing to me
because I felt rightly and wrongly that
I knew the territory you know that I
know where he's from I know what it's
like to be from Massachusetts I don't
think it's changed all that much in the
last you know two hundred years in a
certain way I mean of course it has in
other ways certainly so you know that
was that was interesting to me and your
first two books one was on Leo and
Gertrude Stein right and the other one
Janet Flynn or the Paris correspondent
for The New Yorker and why did that
interest you well I was actually looking
for a subject I wanted to write about a
woman and someone told me that her
papers were here in Washington at the
Library of Congress and I went down came
down to look at them and they cried out
for a biography it seemed to me I hadn't
really thought about biography because
it was the story of so many people
wrapped in her life and the only way to
do justice I felt was to tell it as a
life story and it's a wonderful
narrative I found so interesting so
that's how that happen
you dedicate the book for Michael is it
dallara yeah who is that my husband and
is this the first time you've dedicated
a book to him yeah it's his turn it
started with my grandparents then to my
parents and now the rest are for him
your expectations on a book like this a
live Hawthorn who who did you write it
for you why I mean what did I write it
for you know what Gertrude Stein has a
wonderful line and it's true I think she
has a lot of wonderful lines and hers is
I write for myself in strangers so when
I say you I'm not being glib exactly I
write it for myself I write the book I
want to read in a sense I hope to write
the book that I want to read that I
won't not want to read sometime from now
even when nobody else wants to but also
for strangers because I want to tell a
story and to affect people you know set
up that kind of communication about
things and people and places that I
think are important chapter one first
word of the book guilty yeah you
obviously thought about that I did why
chapter one well this is the story I
mean when when when when one thinks of
Hawthorne one thinks of guilt there
seems to be a kind of shadow of guilt
over everything he writes he's also a
man obsessed by the past his past his
the history of the country the things we
did yesterday conscience however you
talk about the past I thought that
instead of beginning his life with the
past which is the conventional
traditional form for a biography I would
begin it in the future because from some
points of view the future is the past
and so I began the story of Hawthorne
telling you the reader about his
children because I thought that
understanding what happens to his
children is a way of understanding a
kind of story
that gives us an insight into who he is
and was not that it's a causal
relationship he
an ex father that created these children
but because certain patterns in people's
lives get repeated over and over and we
can almost see in the strange lives of
his children we can see certain
obsessions and preoccupations of his his
son is the guilty party Julian Julian at
the beginning of the book he's been he's
been called guilty by a New York Court
who was about to sentence him for mail
fraud but the real crime was trafficking
the Hawthorn name selling shares and a
phony mining stock so here you have the
son of a very famous father and I've
often wondered what happens to the sons
outside of politics that as the sons of
very famous fathers or mothers what
happens to the children well Julian's in
his sixties and he's going to jail
because he's a hawthorn and because he
because he was very conflicted about the
Hawthorn name as his own father was
conflicted about that name because the
father was the grand great-great
grandson of hanging which judges so
that's why the guilt did Julian go to
jail joyeux how long almost a year I
mean he got some time off for time
served but it was almost two years in a
penitentiary in Atlanta what about his
daughters una and rose rose is very
interesting because very very recently
roses the youngest of the three very
very recently a cause was opened up on
behalf of rose Hawthorne that means that
the church is going to put her up the
Catholic Church for sainthood it may
take ten years probably take a hundred
somewhere in between there so the
daughter of the Puritans became
basically a Catholic nun and founded
what is more or less the first Hospice
in the United States for indigent cancer
patients and it still exists in guess
where it's all like a Hawthorne story
place called Hawthorne New York was
named
for father and daughter primarily I have
a lot of firsts in this book with the
horse yeah yeah too much probably too
much but anyway so Rose is going to be
the st. julian's of criminal and you
know the firstborn was she died very
young in a sense like her father it's
not clear why she died she had a unhappy
life and she was what we would call
today probably clinically depressed
and it may have had somatic sources she
had malaria as a young girl in Rome not
sure we finished the Sophia
Elizabeth story or no we left it hanging
yes we did
so how how long was Nathaniel Hawthorne
in the middle of these two women's lies
before he ended up proposing to Sofia
about two years about two years it was
the late 1830s that Elizabeth more or
less found Hawthorne championed
Hawthorne thought he was the most
wonderful writer she she was given to
great enthusiasms but she meant them and
she was sincere about them brought him
home so fire her youngest sister was
seemed to be an invalid she had the
headache a lot and she was she was
unavailable no one thought she would
marry people thought she would you know
just be retiring in her room painting
and that and under Elizabeth's nose more
or less Sophia and Nathaniel began
flirting and and Elizabeth was gracious
about it how long were they married they
were married from 1842 to 64 so that's
20 I didn't see any references to
affairs of Nathaniel Hawthorne in this
book was he loyal to her the whole Oh
exceptionally I'm sure she'll oil to him
apps absolutely
and in death even more loyal absolutely
how long did she live beyond his 1964
day not very much longer
all things considered she died in 1871
so she was still fairly young herself
sure her health improved enormous Lee
because a lot of her problems were
psychosomatic and the marriage helped
them but but she was also given to
somatic ways of dealing with stress and
she got bronchitis and she died in 1871
she wasn't really one to last very long
without him
if nathaniel hawthorne came back today
and walked into one of our big
bookstores yeah inside his picture well
they walked up and saw you know I just
did it yeah and then there you know
there's probably oh let's say 10 or 12
copies of his books including one of
yours sitting there on the Shelf Scarlet
Letter in this house of Seven Gables and
lots of other the marble faun and others
would he be surprised you know I think
yes and no I mean I think there was a
sardonic side to him he would he would
he would feel embittered partly for the
years of neglect to suffer so and then
find this and never to have really
enjoyed the fruits there was bit that I
mean of course he'd be delighted in a
way but I think there would be a way in
which once a person like him feels so so
it neglected as I said I think he never
quite got over it
and it was hard for him so that there
would be a sort of grim sense of
satisfaction that he would take in that
the Scarlet Letter we haven't talked
about plots in any of these books The
Scarlet Letter briefly was what it's a
story of what we today call us a single
mother you know she was unwed Hester
Prynne unwed and will not remember sorry
she was wedg she was but she was Wed to
not the father of her child
and so she bares an illegitimate child
and the pure Puritan community in Boston
17th century
where she lives will have nothing of it
and they put an A on her and she raises
the child for seven years and never
never discloses the name of the child's
father which had she done then life
would have been easier for her the
child's father of course is the town
Reverend a man of great piety and
beloved by his congregation so there are
ironies with an irony that was it's a
true story
no I mean there were true stories like
it I mean there you know there were
women were forced to wear a Zoar
sometimes in the case interestingly
enough in some cases ABS for adultery
and father of Hester's child is Arthur
Dimmesdale ad so anybody in the
community could have gotten it but of
course you know Hawthorne is satirizing
the community there to impact at the
time this was written mmm powerful very
very powerful for two reasons not just
because of the kind of scandalous nature
of the story which it was and passionate
powerful story means amazing woman at
the center of this book who really stays
true to herself no matter how she's
excoriated or punished but also because
he appended to the front of it a little
essay about his being booted out of the
Custom House we talked about that in
which he sent up you know he satirized
all the custom-house core cohorts and
told that he'd been fired in no
uncertain terms so so the first part of
the book created a kind of scandal
that's not scandalous to us anymore
today and then of course the second part
of the book seems shocking it's a novel
of adultery how dare you we're out of
time this cover is what that is a
wonderful portrait of Nathaniel
Hawthorne that actually hangs in a club
in New York City and it was taken it was
done of him when he was about 46 years
old
wine apple our guest Hawthorne a life
thank you very much thank
you